le confinement le plus strict doit
encore se poursuivre jusqu'au lundi 11
mai yes le mec sait mettre l'ambiance
quand même ça va vous
[Applaudissements]
bon on le savait 1 mais quand même ce
genre de trucs
on a beau s'y attendre quand même quand
ça arrive ça fait pas plaisir 1
alors là le truc en plus c'est que la
nouvelle elle tombe un petit peu à un
moment où j'ai l'impression tout le
monde était un peu dans le creux de la
vague
non je sais pas si c'est le cap des 1
mois de confinement si c'est cette
espèce de date butoir du 15 avril qu'on
avait depuis le début même si on savait
que le sait parce qu'il ya mais en tout
cas j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
espèce de baisse de d'entousiasme
généralisée dans ce mouvement bah c'est
vrai que ça dure un peu quand même si
l'histoire maintenant la même si au
début on avait tous pleins d'idées super
sympa pour meubler pourra tout ça mais
en plus le truc c'est qu'on tenait tous
plus ou moins court se disant qu' à la
fin on allait tous se retrouver et que
ça va être la fête du slip et puis que
de toute façon au pire y aurait l'été
pour se rattraper
et puis plus ça va plus on se rend
compte que la sortie ça n'a pas vraiment
être qu'on s'imaginait au début un qui
va falloir rester hyper prudent qu'il va
y avoir encore des règles à respecter
puisque l'été restaurants cafés des
hôtels cinémas théâtres salles de
spectacles et musées resteront en
revanche fermée à ce stade tu m'aides
pas beaucoup la bombe alors du coup on
fait quoi
je veux dire on n'a pas le choix on
oublie de rester enfermé la bonne
nouvelle quand même c'est qu'on a fait
plus de la moitié 1
mais c'est quand même pas la fête
j'avoue du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour pas péter les plombs
attention là on va pas parler des cas de
figure où il ya des éléments très
concrets et très immédiat qui font que
le confinement se passe mal ou très
difficilement comme des problèmes de
santé par exemple ou des histoires de
violence au sein du foyer
pour tout ça je vous remets dans la
description les liens utiles pour savoir
comment agir dans ces situations là on
va pas non plus parler des gens qui
continuent à travailler
par contre ces gens là une nouvelle fois
on va leur dire encore merci un grand
merci parce que c'est grâce à eux si on
va s'en sortir de continuer à vivre
pendant ce temps là là aujourd'hui on va
vraiment parler des gens qui sont
confinés et qui le vivent mal voilà ces
gens là ils ont pris en partant sur le
coin de la tronche quand ils ont appris
que le profil mans ça allait durer
encore un moment
et ils se demandent comment ils vont
faire pour tenir le coup j'ai envie de
vous dire la vie c'est pas attendre que
l'orage passe
la vie c'est apprendre à danser sous la
pluie
sénèque qui a dit ça et comme ces mecs
c'est quand même pas la moitié d'un
conte on va lui faire confiance et on va
essayer d'apprendre à danser sous la
pluie c'est une métaphore donc pour ça
on va d'abord essayer de comprendre
pourquoi on est mal et même avant ça on
va déjà commencer par se dire un truc on
a le droit d'être mal hein je veux dire
ce qu'on est en train de vivre c'est un
truc historique c'est du jamais vu dans
l'époque moderne
donc on a plein de raisons d'être mal ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut rien faire pour
aller mieux
ça veut dire qu'on peut déjà commencer
par se débarrasser de la culpabilité ne
pas aller bien parce que la culpabilité
ça ne sert à rien et ça fait pas du bien
on va déjà à s'enlever ce poids de nos
épaules l'a déjà on se sentira tout de
suite plus léger et puis ça va nous
permettre d'avancer et de faire ce qu'il
faut pour aller mieux
alors ce que je propose cette
culpabilité on l'apprend mon la malaxe
on en fait un petit bol et ont fait caca
dedans et après on jette tout ça et on
tire la chasse le volet est
biodégradable
voyez les métaphores encore déjà ça
devrait aller mieux mais on va passer à
la suite
alors en plus de toutes les raisons
individuelles qu'on a deux pas bien
vivre le confinement que ce soit des
raisons personnelles des raisons
professionnelles des raisons financières
il ya deux grandes causes qui fait qu'on
est mal dans cette situation en ce
moment d'abord on n'est pas bien parce
qu on subit on subit la situation et du
coup on attend on attend que l'orage
passe
diouf
et ensuite on n'est pas bien parce que
on sait pas on ne sait pas quand l'orage
va s'arrêter et on sait pas à quoi ça va
ressembler dehors quand l'orage sera
fini le truc de sénèque toujours ça
c'est des trucs qui sont hyper classique
hyper connue l'ignorance le fait de pas
savoir
ça génère de la peur mène à la colère
colère mène à la lan souffre et la peur
ça génère de l'hostilité
c'est pour ça par exemple qu'on nous
explique pourquoi le train est coincé en
plein milieu de la voie quand ça nous
arrive alors ça nous empêche pas d'être
vénère parce qu'on ait commencé mais au
moins on arrête d'angoissé quand on sait
pourquoi et on est vener parce qu'on
subit justement on a cette impression
qu'on peut rien faire et le sentiment
d'impuissance c'est un truc qu'on gère
pas très bien en général sauf qu'en vrai
il ya plein de trucs qu'on peut faire on
peut pas arrêter la pluie mais on peut
apprendre à danser dessous ça fait
beaucoup de métaphores croiser la no koi
[Musique]
je l'admets cieux suite à l'arrêt de
notre train brieuc indéterminée nous
sommes mobilisés jusqu'à on sait pas
quand bon mais bref vous avez l'idée
l'ignorance et l'impuissance sait les
raisons pour lesquelles on est inquiet
angoissé et en colère maintenant qu'on a
planté le décor on va décliner sa de
façon un petit peu plus concrète entre
le côté vénère déjà on est d'accord
c'est ça soulage
y a pas de mal à se soulager le truc
c'est que si ça devient une habitude sur
le long terme
on rentre vite dans une espèce de
spirale négative qui nous fait pas du
bien donc
première chose on va arrêter de
s'énerver après des trucs contre
lesquelles on peut rien et cette énergie
qu'on a économisé on va la mettre en
oeuvre pour faire des trucs constructif
genre apprendre à danser sous la pluie
on va y revenir après pour l'impuissance
maintenant pour contrer ce côté subi la
lidc d'arrêter de se dire on me force à
rester enfermée chez moi mais c'est
plutôt d'essayer de se rappeler pourquoi
rester chez soi c'est le meilleur moyen
de soulager les hôpitaux et le personnel
soignant qui en chiffres déjà pas mal
c'est le meilleur moyen de protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles et c'est
aussi le meilleur moyen de faire en
sorte que cette épidémie s'arrête
une fois qu'on a réussi à faire ça une
fois qu'on a réussi à redonner du sens
au confinement et à se dire que c'est
une façon positive d'agir on peut se
réapproprier le truc et se dire c'est ça
qu'il faut faire
donc c'est ça que je fais voilà c'est
une espèce de façon d'être dans l'action
donc on subit plus maintenant pour cette
espèce d'angoissé qui est née du fait
qu' on sait pas ce qui va se passer est
qu'on sait pas comment ça va se passer
déjà maintenant on a une date le 11 mai
même si on sait maintenant d'expérience
que c'est le genre de chose qui peut
changer parce qu'on était sur le 15
avril
même si on n'y croyait pas trop le truc
c'est qu'il faut bien garder à l'esprit
que les gens qui décident ils sont comme
nous ils savent pas comment ça va
évoluer savent pas comment ça va se
passer
du coup le déconfinement on sait pas
concrètement non plus comment ça va se
passer pour les mêmes raisons donc on
sait pas on va accepter ça on ne
maîtrise pas l'avenir
on va se concentrer sur la seule chose
qu'on maîtrise un petit peu ici et
maintenant on vit dans l'instant présent
un jour après l'autre un petit peu comme
si on était au pied d'une montagne qu'on
devait escalader et qu'on voyait pas le
sommet si on passe notre temps à
regarder tout en haut
on va avoir le vertige en avoir floué
par la tête qui tourne on va saigner du
nez et on va se décourager alors l'idée
c'est de regarder là où on va mettre la
main la prochaine prise là où on va
mettre le pied et ainsi de suite
une prise après l'autre bavois
l'appareil encore une métaphore je suis
je suis bonfire bon ça c'est pour la
théorie mais du coup en pratique comment
on fait parce que je vous voilà vous
êtes embêté il ya plus de farine
chez franprix vous avez fini tiger king
vous avez relu tous alfred de musset
vous ne savez plus quoi faire vous
ennuyer alors si vous êtes du genre à
avoir besoin de créer de faire des trucs
qui font du sens qui laisse une trace
qui s'inscrivent dans la durée par fait
très bien continuer à mener à bien vos
projets continuer à apprendre des trucs
parfait pas de pas de souci avec ça
juste c'est pas du tout obligé d'être
productif de créer des trucs etc
on n'est pas tous pareils à ce niveau là
c'est très très bien comme ça on a dit
qu'on arrêtait de culpabilité donc on se
fout la paix et on se retire un petit
peu de la pression et tout ça un conseil
qui est valable pour tout le monde par
contre en ce moment l'idéal c'est de
fonctionner à l'envi pour se sentir bien
le top c'est de se blinder de sérotonine
d'endorphines de plein de trucs en chine
et pour ça la règle
faites-vous du bien faites vous plaisir
et drôlement intime
oui 6 non mais c'est ici ça ça marche
mais il ya d'autres trucs aussi alors
quoi d'autre la difficulté à ce stade
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on a dit c'est
qu'on a peut-être faire un petit peu le
tour de ce qu'on avait prévu de faire
parce que ça fait déjà un mois quand
même alors s'il ya des trucs qui
marchent toujours là on change pas une
équipe qui gagne
continuez mais si vous avez du temps à
meubler et que vous avez pu trop d'idées
l'idée c'est de ne pas laisser la
routine s'installe et vous savez ça
mieux tout le monde
la routine c'est la daronne de la
lassitude on n'a pas besoin de ça en ce
moment donc déjà un premier truc vous
avez sûrement constaté ça quand on
commence à mâchouiller son somme on a
tendance à se coller dans des espèces de
boue
c'est les mêmes trucs qui tourne en rond
dans notre tête sans arrêt on fait et on
refait les mêmes choses machinalement de
façon cyclique sans vraiment y prendre
de plaisir on est un peu coincé donc
déjà quand on repère ça il faut péter la
boucle dans 99% des cas
à ce moment là on est passif donc déjà
première chose on se lève et on fait un
truc orange ont fait du ménage on fait
des pompes on va se laver les dents on
tape un petit moon walk on fait
n'importe quoi du moment qu'on fait
autre chose que ce qu'on était en train
de faire et une fois qu'on a cassé la
spirale ou peut passer à un truc qui va
nous faire plaisir
et là mes deux petits conseils pour bien
casser la bouche à la routine picorer et
se surprendre se surprendre en partant
du principe qu'on a déjà fait tout ce
qu'on avait prévu de faire eh ben c'est
faire des trucs qu'on n'avait pas prévu
de faire voir qu'on a jamais fait ne
serait-ce que juste pour essayer pour
voir si on aime ça et on peut surprendre
même si on est confiné solo 1 on en
allant fouiner sur internet
vous connaissez en demandant aux potes
ce qu'ils font eux ça peut donner des
idées
ou alors en jouant à un petit jeu que
j'ai inventé personnellement et que
j'appelle le jeu de l'exorciste c'est à
dire en pivotant la tête de cette façon
voilà vous tournez la tête vous regardez
autour de vous et votre regard va
s'arrêter sur des trucs qui vont vous
donner des idées genre vous tombez sur
un bloc notes
vous pouvez écrire sur un bloc notes
l'écriture automatique
c'est hyper bien c'est hyper libérateur
c'est vachement chouette vous pouvez
dessiner même si vous ne savez pas
dessiner on s'en fout vous pouvez faire
des origamis vous pouvez faire plein de
trucs je suis pas aveugle darron non
plus mais vous avez trouvé des idées
votre regard et va peut-être s'arrêter
sur un bouquin sur une bd sur un truc
que vous avez jamais lus ba ouvrait le
feuilleter un et puis vous verrez bien
si ça vous plaît il va peut-être
s'arrêter juste pas sur votre four et
ben c'est le moment de faire un gratin
de nouilles aux pattes ou un truc comme
ça
bref vous allez forcément trouver
quelque chose et de toute façon si vous
trouvez pas tout de suite c'est pas
grave parce que mon autre conseil c'est
de picorer alors c'est un peu chelou dit
comme ça mais quand quelqu'un arrive pas
trop à manger
le conseil qu'on lui donne ses de
fractionner ses repas c'est à dire de
manger régulièrement
petite quantité au lieu de faire genre
deux ou trois gros repas et voilà vous
fait pareil avec vos activités vous
variez vous fait plein de choses
différentes vous essayer des trucs déjà
ça ça va faire passer le temps et puis
évidemment si à un moment vous tombez
sur un truc qui vous plaît vous
continuez et puis vous recommencez les
jours d'après c'est le moment de tenter
des trucs c'est le moment donné on a dit
qu'on se foutait la paix avec la
culpabilité
eh ben on ose aussi lançons-nous si vous
avez envie de danser en slip dans votre
salon danser en slip dans votre salon
qui va vous jugez moi le confinement
l'inactivité l'inertie tout ça on en
avait parlé dans la dernière vidéo
c'est des choses qui sont bonnes ni pour
la santé mentale ni pour la santé
physique
donc n'hésitez pas à retourner et choper
quelques petits conseils pour rester en
bonne santé parce que on sera très
content d'être en forme
quand on va sortir parce que ça sera
peut-être pas tout à fait comme on a
imaginé ça sera quand même vachement
mieux que maintenant on sera hyper
content et on sera joyeux de pouvoir en
profiter en pleine forme en pleine santé
un et puis pensez à tout ce qui apaise
physiquement de façon immédiate
vous pouvez prendre un bain si vous
voulez une baignoire d'une touche ça
peut ça peut marcher aussi faut faire de
la méditation des exercices de
respiration abdominale ou de cohérence
cardiaque
des séances d'auto hypnose de
sophrologie à base de lâcher prise et
c'est il ya plein d'appli à plein de
vidéos en plus en ce moment il y en a
pas mal qui sont gratuites sur sur
internet donc cherché fouiner vous allez
trouvez vous avez compris le secret est
fait d'accepter le fait que bon c'est
pas que je ne peux pas trop prévoir on
peut pas trop anticiper donc de vivre
dans l'instant présent et se laisser
guider par ses envies et son plaisir
attention ça veut pas dire devenir
complètement égoïste et complètement
auto centré mais ça veut dire déjà
réussir à être bien avec soi même parce
que en ce moment plus que jamais on a
vraiment besoin de ça après c'est clair
que un autre moyen d'être bien avec
soi-même et des biens tout court c'est
de s'occuper aussi un petit peu des
autres
juste en prenant des nouvelles
en témoignant un petit peu de soutien à
des gens qui sont en difficulté en
smalltalk en rigolant avec les potes ça
fait toujours du bien aux autres et à
soi ou en rendant des services ce soit
aux gens de notre cercle proche à nos
voisins et pourquoi pas si on a la
ressource et qu'on se sent à des gens
complètement inconnu il ya plein de gens
qui ont besoin d'être en ce moment le
paradoxe c'est qu'on n'a jamais été
aussi seul qu'en ce moment mais en même
temps on n'a jamais eu autant besoin des
autres c'est un petit peu vrai tout le
temps mais là en ce moment c'est
particulièrement exacerbée bas
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos en attendant prenez soin de vous
prenons soin les uns des autres
ça va venu je suis venu faire le kéké
pendant son allocution moi non en plus
c'est pas comme ça qu'on dit c'est
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien le sans-gêne du mec quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]